What determines our intelligence?
One school of thought is that,
ok maybe, you are either just
born with it, either have it or you don't.
Some people are smart,
some people are less smart,
or maybe you can change it.
And it turns out there's actually been a lot
of research on this in the last few decades.
And
the answer is pretty clear that
your intelligence
can actually be changed.
What we've learned, what researchers have taught us,
is that our brains are actually a lot like a muscle.
We know that you can grow your muscles
by going into the gym,
and doing exercise,
and straining your muscles.
You don't  just work on things that are easy for your muscles to do;
you do things that your muscles have to struggle with,
that your muscles have to strain with
and then they rebuild themselves
and they come back stronger.
By struggling, its a signal to your body
to devote more resources
to that part of the body.
And we see that exact same thing with the brain .
And here, just a couple of examples
of it.
This is first one,
This shows how
the human brain develops
in early childhood.
This is a depiction of the
neurons in a brain
at birth.
And then over time, as a child develops
It interacts with its environment,
it tries things out,
it struggles to talk,
to converse,to interact with folks,
to understand the world around it.
And as it struggles,
by age 6 you have a much
deeper and much stronger connectedness
between the different neurons.
Similarly, similarly,
I can never say that word,
These are depictions of, these are the neurons
of two different scenarios.
This is the nerves
of animals ,
that were in un stimulating environments:
where they are not around other animals.
They are in a bear cage.
This is the brain
of an animal that is
in a stimulating environment,
that is constantly being challenged,
that is constantly looking at
stimulating new things.
And so the big take away
from this whole area of research
is you absolutely can change
your intelligence.
That your brain is like a muscle
the more you use it,the stronger it gets
and that the best way to grow it
isn't to do things that are easy for you.
That might help a little bit
but what really helps your brain
is when you struggle with things.
And actually research shows that your brain
grows the most not when you get a question right,
but when you get a question wrong.
So at least for me this is incridibly exciting
because, unless we know
that when I'm going through something.
And I'm facing those times of maybe a little bit of  adversity,
or a little bit of frustration.
I can -
feel good about the fact that those
are actually the times that I'm growing the most.
And this isn't just something that I'm saying
nice words. Research tells us that when
you get something wrong,
when you challenge your brain,
when you review why you got it wrong,
when you really process that feedback ,
that's when your brain grows the most.
And then if you keep doing that
you are well on your way to having a stronger, more able,
and I guess ,smarter brain.